[Music]
on this Sunday night a mass shooting
near a Lunar New Year celebration the
search for the suspect after 10 people
are killed we don't know if this is
specifically a hate crime defined by law
Plus without water I'm using rain water
in here to even wash my hands with the
small Arizona community facing dire
supply shortages after a severe drought
and bidding farewell some would say but
a broken heart was a doing of her death
hundreds gather at Graceland for Lisa
Marie Presley's public Memorial
global national with foreign assert
reporting tonight
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
police in California say the suspect in
a mass shooting during Lunar New Year
celebrations is now dead SWAT officers
surrounded a white van for hours today
trying to determine whether a man
barricaded inside was the person
responsible for taking the lives of 10
people
as Torrance officers pulled behind the
vehicle the white van entered a shopping
Center parking lot
when officers exited their patrol
vehicle to contact the occupant they
heard one gunshot
coming from within the van
police say the 72-year-old suspect died
at the scene from a self-inflicted
gunshot wound investigators found
several items inside the van connecting
him to the crime scene as Jennifer
Johnson reports police are now trying to
figure out what motivated this latest
mass shooting in the U.S
additional units requested multiple
victims gunshot wounds a celebration
turned into a nightmare after a gunman
opened fire inside a crowded ballroom
dance studio in Monterey Park Witnesses
say the suspect described as an Asian
male pulled out a gun and began shooting
wildly he reportedly fled in a white van
several hours later a Police SWAT team
pulled over a similar looking vehicle
about 45 kilometers away the driver was
found inside dead there is a tactical
Incident That's occurring in the city of
Torrance that are is being covered
uh people have asked is that you're
suspect
we don't know police in the FBI are
investigating whether this was a hate
crime the community is home to mostly
Asian immigrants or first generation
Asian Americans
last night's celebration was part of a
two-day Lunar New Year event that has
attracted up to 100 000 people to this
small City in previous years many
outside the club first mistook the
gunfire for fireworks
very surprising shocking to hear that
something like this went on in
not only a small City but my city
investigators are looking into whether a
man who pulled out a gun at another
Ballroom Studio later Saturday night in
nearby Alhambra is connected to this
case patrons apparently wrestled that
man to the ground but he got away local
residents and leaders are devastated
this is a time to be with family
to celebrate
and yet this tour a hole through all of
our hearts this tragedy is the fifth
mass murder shooting in the U.S this
year and is the deadliest since May 2022
when 21 people were killed in a school
in Uvalde Texas 2022 was one of the
nation's Worst Years for mass killings
U.S President Joe Biden tweeted that he
and the first lady are praying for those
killed and injured while some in
Congress are again demanding stricter
gun laws we're dealing with the tragedy
of mass shootings which is a sadly a
uniquely American experience it happens
over and over and over again now another
Community will be burying friends and
loved ones in the days to come as the
investigation into why this happened
begins Jennifer Johnson Global News
Washington
the shooting in California is hitting
home at Lunar New Year celebrations
across Canada prime minister Justin
Trudeau attending festivities in
Vancouver he acknowledged the tragedy
and says his government will be there
for whatever support Canada can offer
of course these celebrations will be
tinged with sadness and support for the
community in in California that is
reeling right now after the horrific
news coming out last night in Monterey
Park
in Turkey there is uproar and political
tension over a far-right demonstration
in Sweden thousands are now showing
their anger after an anti-islam
politician was allowed to protest
outside the Turkish Embassy in Stockholm
and then burned the Quran the holy text
of Islamic faith and as Mackenzie gray
explains the backlash to this hateful
Act is now jeopardizing Sweden's hopes
of joining NATO at the 11th Hour
there's outrage in Ankara and across
turkey for the second day in a row
protesters furious at the Swedish
government
foreign
the burning of a Quran outside the
Turkish Embassy in Stockholm
but this completely reasonable request
The Man Behind it is Rasmus Paul Dean a
Danish politician the leader of a
far-right anti-islam party that has no
seats in the Danish Parliament they were
seemingly more police than protesters at
the demonstration but the fact it was
sanctioned at all has Turks up in arms
it's unacceptable that Swedish
authorities are allowing such kind of
provocative action in front of an
embassy said this protester
we cannot accept the burning of a Quran
Under the Umbrella of freedom of
expression and human rights out of this
politician the Swedish foreign minister
has called The Burning appalling but a
more blunt message in the window of the
Swedish Consulate at Istanbul we do not
share that book burning idiot's View
[Music]
a diplomatic row between Sweden and
turkey is far-reaching international
consequences even for Canada
Sweden dumped its policy of neutrality
after Russia's invasion of Ukraine and
asked to join NATO but the only way into
the alliance approval from all 30
members including turkey the Turkish
government has given a long list of
Demands to the swedes including the
Banning of Kurdish groups that are
outlawed in turkey and considered
terrorist groups by the U.S and EU as
well as extraditing alleged Kurdish
Fighters living in Sweden the swedes say
they can't fulfill all of turkey's
demands but they're still confident
they'll be led into NATO We Believe very
strongly what we have done what was
being asked by us and we do not see any
reason the public ratification not to
start Canada was the first country to
approve Sweden's NATO membership but it
looks like in the end it will be up to
Turkey to decide if they'll get in
Mackenzie gray Global News Audible
in Syria at least 16 people have been
killed after a building collapsed in the
northern city of Aleppo dozens of
firefighters First Responders and
residents are combing through the rubble
for survivors the building housed about
30 people in a neighborhood under the
control of kurdish-led Syrian Democratic
forces they blame the Syrian government
for obstructing efforts to stabilize and
Restore Life in the area many buildings
in Aleppo were destroyed or damaged
during Syria's 11-year conflict
U.S President Joe Biden faces more
political scrutiny after more old
classified documents were found in his
Delaware home according to Biden's
lawyer the FBI discovered six more
sensitive files at the home during a
nearly 13-hour search on Friday
voluntarily Allowed by the president
some documents were from his time as
vice president in the Obama
Administration others from his time as
Senator it's the latest batch of files
after Biden's attorney's previously
revealed others were found at the home
and at a former office
a dire situation is unfolding in a small
Arizona community where residents have
been cut off from access to drinking
water in the middle of an extensive
ongoing drought the unincorporated
community of Rio Verde Foothills sits
just outside the city of Scottsdale and
until a few weeks ago it trucked in
water from the city that was until the
Taps were turned off Jackson prosco
reports on a community running dry in a
state where water is increasingly scarce
these are tough times for the 2400
residents of Rio Verde Foothills we're
just using our buckets
right now and collecting the rain water
they're forced to save every drop of
water because they have no other choice
I'm using rain water in here to even
wash my hands with to rinse dishes with
for flushing the toilets The Crisis
began three weeks ago after the nearby
city of Scottsdale stopped selling water
to residents of the unincorporated
Community where homes are not connected
to any water supply I just cannot
believe that a group of people
would look at their neighbors and say
we're going to slowly kill off your
community for years Scottsdale with its
Lush golf courses had manicured Lawns
has warned its water supplies were
getting tight after three decades
supplying Rio Verde Foothills the Taps
were finally turned off January 1st they
should manage their own destiny with
their own water we have to adapt and
then we have to adapt more and we have
to adapt more just crack that faucet
when you rinse okay the result is that
families like the Rhymes can't bathe or
do laundry or dishes as they try to
stretch what little is left in their own
water tanks we probably have about a
week to two weeks they're left to rely
on private trucks to haul in water from
increasingly expensive and far-flung
locations when you have to pay more for
water than your mortgage is also crazy
and that's the situation we're in right
now experts warn it's a cautionary tale
about living off the grid in an era when
water is increasingly scarce it really
was not reasonable for them to expect
that they had a forever Supply the best
hope may come from a Canadian company
epcor which has proposed building a
dedicated supply for residents if
approved it would take at least two
years to build the solution is feasible
there'll be some difficult times we'll
have to negotiate with a couple
different interested stakeholders in
terms of making sure that their water
rights are you know preserved until then
residents of Rio Verde Foothills are
living on borrowed time and borrowed
water my community is beautiful it's the
most special place in Arizona
and if it doesn't have water for the
people that live there it's gonna die
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
population boom or bust coming up
Atlantic provinces are growing but will
it have a positive impact for residents
[Music]
the Vancouver Canucks fired head coach
Bruce Boudreau this morning after rumors
swirled for several days of an impending
coaching change Canucks GM Patrick Alvin
acknowledged the emotional reaction from
Vans but says he's focused on the team's
long-term Direction
this is a decision that based on results
and based on a process and where we are
right now when we're where we want to
move forward here
this is not something we came up with uh
you know last week this has been on top
of my mind here uh since I took the job
and where we envisioned this club going
replacing Boudreau as head coach is Rick
Tonkin
The Maritime Provinces are taking stock
of a mixed blessing a phenomenal
population increase in some cities The
Surge is filling labor gaps and making
communities more diverse but as Ross
Lord reports there's a challenge in
preventing the influx from making
conditions worse in Health Care and
housing
as the population of Canada approaches
the 40 million Mark the way we're
growing has led to a phenomenal trend on
the East Coast we want people to move
here we want people to settle and choose
Nova Scotia as their home and it's
working the population of Canada grew by
1.8 percent last year with cities
growing by 2.1 percent here's where
things get unusual the fastest growing
cities are Halifax at 4.4 percent and
Monkton New Brunswick at 5.3 it's the
first time in decades Maritime Urban
centers have led the way this past year
has really seen a boost in in flows from
other other parts of Canada Danny
Waldman and his family moved recently
from Toronto to the Halifax area we had
spent many years there we started to
raise our kids there we are outdoor
people and really wanted to be much
closer to the water and when covid hit
my wife had this sense that now was the
time and and here we are the Terrell
family also left Southern Ontario to
start a new life in small town New
Brunswick there were a lot of pluses on
getting out of Ontario and getting to a
smaller Community uh out here as well
you know to try and Stave off catching
covet any way we could Terrell says the
movie is working out he and his wife
found jobs quickly more difficult was
finding a family doctor it's definitely
a little more challenging than Ontario
attracting newcomers to fill labor gaps
without compounding problems in housing
and Health Care isn't easy we have some
of these social issues and challenges
that are rising up but at the same time
we have incredible investment in our
community so trying to to keep both
things balanced is the Eternal challenge
right now to get that balance right the
Nova Scotia government is recruiting
more health care workers from overseas
and refining immigration strategies so a
couple different working groups and
committees have been uh are in the works
of forming and meeting the stakes are
high especially for a Health Care System
plagued by a growing number of emergency
room horror stories these aren't easy
easy problems to solve but uh the the
reality is we do need more people here
analysts say continuing the maritime's
population momentum desperately requires
more housing construction otherwise they
say newcomers will move on to other
destinations Ross Lord Global News
Halifax
[Music]
ahead hundreds gather to mourn at Lisa
Marie Presley's Memorial
[Music]
Lisa Marie Presley was laid to rest
today a memorial service for the only
child of Elvis Presley was held on the
lawn at Graceland in Memphis Tennessee
the home where she lived with Elvis as a
child as Mike Armstrong explains her
life was filled with twists and turns
and the service was emotional
there was a challenge for the organizers
behind the service
according to the first Speaker of the
day among Lisa Marie Presley's wishes
for how she wanted to be remembered were
four words
don't make it sad
[Music]
Lisa we will try to honor you and honor
your wish today
[Music]
it may have been a simple request but it
was one that was hard to deliver Presley
died earlier this month of a cardiac
arrest at just 54 years old just a few
days earlier she'd attended the Golden
Globes and walked the red carpet with
someone she knew her entire life Jerry
Schilling was a close friend of Elvis
and later gave Lisa Marie her first job
working as his assistant every couple of
weeks she would come in a very
disgruntled look on her face
somebody else wants to talk to you about
Lisa Marie they had no idea they were
talking to her over the phone
she was famous from the day she was born
the only child of Elvis Presley she
dealt with the weight of that Fame but
also carried Pride when Elvis died in
1977 Lisa Marie was at home with him at
Graceland she inherited the residence
and it eventually became a museum to the
Man known as the king of rock and roll
she was a conduit to the throne The
Keeper of the flame
she was the image of a king
Presley had struggles it was a battle
with addiction a business manager who
cost her millions and four marriages
including one to Michael Jackson but
there was also a more recent tragedy the
death by suicide in 2020 of her only son
survivors
guilt some would say but a broken heart
was a doing of her death
so Marie Presley is being buried at
Graceland near her father and directly
beside her son Mike Armstrong Global
News
actor Jeremy Renner is still on the mend
weeks after a freak snow plow accident
threatened his life in an Instagram post
the 52-year-old Avengers actor thanked
everyone for their messages and
thoughtfulness he also reveals he broke
more than 30 bones but says they will
mend and grow stronger Renner was
crushed by his own snow plow while
operating it on New Year's Day he
suffered multiple chests and Orthopedic
injuries and required multiple surgeries
[Music]
next a look at how Lunar New Year is
being marked around the world
[Music]
from London to Beijing Lunar New Year
events were still in full swing around
the world today with many partaking in
festivities and prayers to Mark the
start of the year of the rabbit an
important celebration in East Asian
culture though some festivities in this
country are more subdued and somber in
light of the tragedy in the U.S Lunar
New Year events were also underway
across Canada shinshin Fung is an expert
on Chinese culture and traditions at the
Concordia University of Edmonton and an
organizer of a celebration there I spoke
with her earlier this weekend on its
importance for students and the Chinese
community
thank you so much for joining us first
of all tell us what's happening at the
Student Center
okay first of all happy Luna New Year so
we're here to celebrate the the Lunar
New Year of the rabbit at Concordia
University of Edmonton my Chinese
language course students are going to
sing the Chinese New Year song they just
learned and the Concordia alumni are
going to perform a fancy Kung Fu show
and behind me you can see we have the
extension continuing education students
are performing Tai Chi and we have a
workshop on Chinese first list hosted by
a Chinese Vision teacher and we have the
calligraphy Workshop hosted by
International exchange students you can
see a lot of decorations in red here Red
Lanterns red Chinese knots redfish red
apples I'm going to give out a lot of
red envelopes to the lucky people and as
you mentioned according to Chinese
astrology this is the year of the water
rabbit what does this represent for 2023
okay sure so the year of the rabbit
according to the Chinese culture the
water falls into the five elements of
five
um the water the fire the Earth the wood
and the metal and the water rabbit will
appear every 60 years as a five elements
were together with the 12 Zodiac or we
call the Earthly branches and the Asian
agricultural Chinese Society there's a
saying when the rabbit water year comes
there's short spring and the fall what
does it mean if you look at the Chinese
lunar calendar in 2023 you actually will
see two favorites that probably just
means there's going to be a long winter
and the long summer so we always believe
for the year of the rabbit if you are
born in the year of the rabbit you are
supposed to be a generous tender
ingenuine and get along with well with
your friends around you and we have a
prediction this year going to be the
year of the hope and according to the
Chinese New Year
prediction this year we'll have more
funny baby born according to the
Democratic demographic statistics on the
year of the rabbit always have the
highest birth rate in China I guess
Chinese parents love the bunnies I guess
that is what that highlights isn't it
we'll let you get back to your event now
shinshin thank you so much for inviting
us there and for your Insight
thank you happy Lunar New Year
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm nitu garcha we leave
you tonight with scenes from Montreal's
Lunar New Year celebrations as our
thoughts remain with all those affected
by the Monterey Park tragedy thanks so
much for watching Donna will be back
with you tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
thank you